tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj allo ragazzi si corre
nelle vacanze non le vacanze di natale
non sarò a casa quindi non potrà
registrare video per circa un paio di
settimane poi ve lo dirò nel blog
comunque ho deciso di fare i banchi e se
l'ho fatto soltanto due giorni fa perché
almeno così vi ricordate dove siamo
perché sono poi non ci ricordiamo più
del cazzo siamo arrivati già non me lo
ricordo più io e quindi direi di andare
avanti con i bar che se l'abbiamo fatto
recentemente che a dare eravamo rimasti
che sta tizia cioè mary era praticamente
una ragazza di di un quadro non è una
che si è persa in galleria anche con
garry raga non ho capito che cosa dovrei
fare devo trovare altre due palline ok
va bene ma dove cazzo del cloud 2
palline anche gli ero preso c'era stata
la testa era bellissima qualcosa esce
qualcosa esce fuori la sua testa cosa
dovrei fare controllare la bambola non è
certo è che adesso il cervello credo che
guardano meglio anche se non voglio
toccarla ma fiscale a un calcio e fai
prima una palla si ok ma ne manca una
ragazza ne manca una palla di vernice
sparita canzoni di ragazzi io allora
affermano non ti permetto non ti
permetto di scappare mi sono appena
ricordate le devo stendere i panni
arrivederci ragazzi allora il nostro
tentativo perché non ho capito come mai
ci sono due miliardi di bambole c'è la
palla se l'ultima che mi rimane poi ho
finito l'arcobaleno premente posso
prenderla chiave ma dove raggiunge alla
cazzo
ok c'è qualcosa per terra ottenuta parla
di vernice bianca
ok adesso via dai cazzo veloce e sono
sette no perché non siamo ragazzi si
apre non si apre la porta è apparsa una
scritta sulla porta facciamo un'altra
caccia al tesoro che chi ha la chiave
che cosa
ragazzi che cosa e adesso io mi sto
giocando tutto questo non va bene e dove
la chiave devo trovare devo trovare la
chiave data da uno di questi
[Musica]
ragazzi che cazzo successo secolo berna
ok ok ok ok mi sento all'interno che
schifo ok ragazzi e ragazze latrano st
chiave ok ok quel tizio sta uscendo la
squadra non è normale bottiglia di
capelli [ __ ] stesso sesso
poi diventato tutto rosso sia morti
perché c'è i ragazzi sono morto è
fantastico
il bello è che stavo armi a si sblocca
tall arcobaleno capirà va bene la
pallina l'ho presa lo stesso quindi
l'arcobaleno lo sbloccato quindi posso
prendere la chiave fino allora la chiave
dopo anni di ricerche e cielo ed è
incredibile non ci posso credere ma non
l'ho capito che cosa è successo a gerry
ci sono morto che è successo allora
innanzitutto dove la meta chiave che non
ho capito ancora che cosa mi serve cielo
ma non ho capito cosa mi serve la fase
in questa porca [ __ ] sua porta vediamo
cosa ci fa 8 ed in un quadro non ho
capito che cosa mi è servita st chiara
dalla sveglia o che cos'è meri aspetta
ibra se senti ci sono scale anche qui
vengo con te ce ne manca non è che tutto
sta voglia di portarmi una pizza che è
uscita da un quadro delle mutande perché
non so dove se la mette quando camminano
insieme penso nelle mutande la porta si
può sbloccare solo la questo dato è slot
che dovrebbe dovrebbe essere la forza di
garry law faber
c'è la fiera è tutto sto casino vero ho
certo a volte sì sì sento qualcuno
parlare riga reagan fatemi salvare
fatevi salvare prima di entrare lì
dentro alla spesa n'attimo suo casinò è
servito alla fine per trovare garry cioè
non si vede tutti i giorni vero sono
scappato capisci o lo adoro ma ci vuole
un po di tempo ragazzi che cazzo fanno
ma si sono messi a un tavolo a bere il
tè o anche tu cavolo li otteniamo
d'accordo non è così ieri e dietro la
porta sta parlando con qualcuno entra
come sono finite le bambole che cosa ci
fa un coniglio enorme carrier dei propri
infrante nente sai tenta di poterti
parlare la mia preoccupazione
i ragazzi e ieri si è fatto di cocaina è
davvero jerry a qualcosa che non va ma
dai
forse un finto c'è il vero ieri non
sarebbe qui giusto non credi ibra che
casa five cosa fa
non l'ha detto prima mai mollare ragazze
che sta andato di testa mio dio li
mandiamo cioè non ti sta ascoltando
troviamo uscito che ieri un adulto
quindi penso che verrà dopo
ok andiamo alle scale caino startene
solo tali sono sicuro che usciremo
presto farò del mio meglio per te
usciremo insieme sì che cazzo fa è
svenuta l'ha travolta
allora svegliate a svegliare vengono
tutti i boy che vado avanti io sicura
stupida ti avevo detto che saremmo
usciti insieme ma credo che dovrà uscire
da sola ragazzini finché se ne va melia
me non me ne frega una mazza basta che
sono con garry però non ho capito che
cosa è successo
fa niente vado via da sola lo giuro
adesso sono con mary dimenticai regata
adesso sono solo con mary beghelli sono
rimasti lì e che cazzo succede tanto non
posso salvare perché non posso salvare
non posso salvare la partita con mary
fantastico fare la gamud capito io torni
indietro solo non so perché non al
capitolo satori allora ho scoperto tutto
e non mi ricordo credo dia già vero
questa però non posso passare perché c'è
sta roba qui quindi non posso
poi sposati un attimo devo scendere ma
che cazzo succede qui ragazzi ma ma non
potevi farlo prima da dio vi ama ci
abbiamo messo anni per sposta sta roba
ma potevi farlo prima ancora un po sono
così vicina così vicino a cosa raga
stati dove stai andando non sono cazzi
tuoi ragazzi sto tizio non ho capito
dove sta andando questa l'entrata questa
entrata del museo che cazzo succede non
è possibile siamo di nuovo all'inizio
all'inizio del museo ragazzi non
aspettate non ha senso come è possibile
che siamo all'inizio nel museo quella è
la l'uscita che cos'è sta roba non
andare di là e io vado di qua [ __ ]
facciamo così torniamo al quadro che sa
che ha fatto iniziare tutto sto casino
che era torna indietro non torni
indietro a vico via devi farti un mazzo
così di cazzi tua se non l'hai capito ok
allora devo andare allora questo è il
quadro iniziale mondo eccomi è questo
qui
ok che ha fatto cosa posso uscire da qui
posso finalmente andare all'esterno non
ci credo mangiano tante caramelle andrò
in un sacco di posti e mi farò un sacco
di amici ma veramente non c è uscita è
uscita così non ci però non ci crederò
mai siamo tornati nel museo quello
originale cioè siamo fuori sono uscita
questo l'esterno ce l'ho fatta
noi ragazzi adesso se vedo la gente mi
incazzo ce ne sono qui è anche da questa
parte della galleria non ci posso
veramente credere che che sia uscita
mary and sia rimasta dentro ma siamo
veramente usciti e ci posso andare di
qua c'è l'uscita una porta e un'uscita e
non lo so la porta non si apre su ca su
kakà non si apre bloccata e ora voglio
solo uscire non puoi e si è spenta la
luce è tornato tutto come prima
ragazzi sto rifacendo l'inizio di ibd
praticamente non si torna indietro non
si va da nessuna parte è però è ben
chiaro ragazzi non è che possono
lasciare i libri indietro e fanno uscire
sta tizia che non si sa neanche chi è
se deve salvarsi qualcuno deve salvarsi
non questa dai quadro quadro qui prima
cos'è questo giu nell'oscurità vieni
mary klose è sesto devo tornare vabbè
allora probabilmente devo tornare di
sotto però non ho capito come mai è
sparito il quadro sta cosa non mi è
nuova comunque allora questa demon non
si va indietro credo che debba turi
tuffarmi nel quadro questo non devo fare
unità che non si può non passato farvi
di nuovo né acqua cos'è spesa da un
attimo che c'è una scritta ok c'è
qualcuno a giusto in caso
cos'è che cazzo non appartieni a questo
luogo ragazzi che cazzo succede c'è c'è
una sbavatura perché c'è una sbavatura
sul soffitto perché sta sento cucciola
re qualcosa perché c'è del nero ragazzi
che cazzo succede
ho paura aiutatemi senti io non so che
cosa cazzo sta succedendo ragazzi
ragazzi sta diventato tutto buio non si
sta oscurando tutto lo vedo più niente
ok non vedo più un cazzo cosa succede
non vedo più niente non vedo neanche io
perchè perchè è così dovrebbe in tutto
essere chiara e divertente e pieno di
persone fuori perché sono ancora qui
ragazzi non è perché non lo so dove sei
sono sola così impari abbandonare la
frutta stranzi o così power aiuto kurry
kurry c'è qualcuno chi sta bene è padre
padre chi padre maronno ragazzo in un
assenso ragazzi è morto o painting di
mais and cosa
ragazzi credo di aver finito il gioco in
uno dei finali perché veramente ce ne
sono mi avete detto che ci sono undici
finali c'è una cosa impressionante non
ho capito ho finito il gioco preto
finito il ceo fitto uno degli undici
finali me ne mancherebbero 10 e vidi
ragazzi mi mancano ancora altri dieci
finali ma credo che farò un episodio che
li contiene tutti quanti e i commenti
ragazzi dovete scrivermi come a fare gli
altri finali perché non ho capito che
cosa devo fare per sbloccarli comunque
questo era uno dei tanti finali ce ne
sono tantissimi in un che voglio vedere
come il cazzo se la cava ed è come se la
cava gjergj devo riuscire a finire con
gli altri fatemi sapere come faccio
perché non ho la più pallida idea
dunque ragazzi 6 video è piaciuto common
solito lasciato un commento vi piace
anche la poesia di facebook e comunali
video trovato nella descrizione essere
tristi discrete noi ci mettiamo nel
prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]